in 2019 jeff kosov published the 26
words that created the internet the
definitive biography of the
controversial law known as section 230.
part of the 1996 communications decency
act section 230 grants broad immunity to
websites and internet service providers
from legal actions based on user
generated content
section 230 is the law that enabled the
participatory nature of the web from
youtube videos to yelp reviews to
basically all of twitter and facebook
it's the reason why reason can't be sued
for libelous or defamatory content
posted in our comments section though
the authors of such comments can be now
kasiff who teaches cybersecurity law at
the united states naval academy is back
with the united states of anonymous how
the first amendment shaped online speech
his new book looks at the history of and
controversy surrounding anonymous speech
activism and more
before becoming a law professor kosov
worked as a journalist at the oregonian
where he was a finalist for a pulitzer
prize and the winner of a george polk
award i talked with him about why he
thinks anonymous speech is generally a
good thing but getting harder to
maintain why democrats and republicans
alike keep freaking out over section 230
and how his past as a journalist informs
his interest in protecting freedom of
speech and assembly here's the reason
interview with jeff kossoff jeff costa
thanks for talking
thanks for having me
so uh you know let's start with the
elevator pitch for the united states of
anonymous
yeah so i wrote this book because
we've had a lot of focus in recent years
on various issues related to free speech
including
misinformation and section 230 and one
area that i feel has not been adequately
addressed is the ability of people
particularly in marginalized groups to
be able to
speak without having the repercussions
of their real name being associated with
that speech and
so it seemed like an odd enough concept
for me to spend a few years researching
and what i found was that it
the the right to speak anonymously
online while not absolute
is very strong and it's tied to a
history that goes back to the founding
of our country so
this book really explores the values
that our country has placed on anonymity
and how the law has incorporated it yeah
you know and it's funny if you're of a
certain vintage as i am uh you know i
remember aol uh i remember aol i could
stop right there but the actual selling
point of aol as the internet and kind of
email and uh you know the web became a
thing one great thing about aol was that
you picked a stupid name
uh that was anonymous it was a tag and
they were actually quite uh good about
protecting the anonymity of their users
as opposed to compuserve and prodigy the
other two popular
commercial services that gave people
kind of access to the internet we're
going to talk about aol and
anonymity uh in a bit but let's start
with uh you know just anonymous speech
in america particularly in you know the
colonial period and the early or you
know the
pre-republic period um you know there's
a couple of very famous cases of
anonymous speech being super important
to what we call the united states talk a
little bit about that and you know the
federalist papers and you know what what
it meant to be able to
have the right to speak uh
pseudonymously or anonymously
so the majority of
the really controversial political
writings in
the
pre-revolutionary period
was published anonymously or
pseudonymously primarily there were all
of these very colorful pen names or
people just would not sign any names to
them at all and there were a variety of
reasons
in part
it was just to protect the individual's
safety and protect from any legal or
criminal threats at the time
other
aspects were
to protect their jobs
and also really to
distance their identities from their
speech because the identity of someone
who even was in power or had a powerful
position
might
perhaps taint the message that they're
trying to get out because there's
baggage that's associated with their
identity so
they wanted to
to set up an identity like a farmer from
pennsylvania rather than a lawyer who
has been active in politics
thomas paine he signed common sense as
written by an englishman
and the there were varying levels of
anonymity some people
it was speculated that they were
the authors uh other people even to this
day we don't know we might have a narrow
group of people who are the authors
to ratify the constitution for example
hamilton madison and jay wrote the
federalist papers but they signed it as
publius
a roman ruler from 500 bc
and there
there were there was a close group of
people with whom they shared that they
were the authors and there was a lot of
speculation but at least for right at
the time
there were a lot of readers who did not
know and the idea was that
these arguments had a different effect
than coming from these three very
prominent political leaders so can i ask
about that because it you know there's
it's a double-edged sword and you you
kind of talk about this so on the one
hand you know if it's if it's alexander
hamilton talking and obviously he's more
famous now because of the play than he
was perhaps in colonial or
pre-revolution or pre-constitutional
america but
you know it's one thing if it's coming
from a political partisan um and that
also you know if if that person has a
good reputation that will help sell the
argument but it also might make people
peel away is it that
using beyond all the safety concerns um
using a pseudonym kind of forces people
to look at the argument rather than you
know it arguing from authority it does
and that's why a pseudonym is so
important because it's a persistent
identifier that can stay with someone so
and even on the internet today there are
people who post under pseudonyms
and i i don't know
who they actually are but
they might have a reputation for being
very thoughtful there are some times
when
the lack of
a real name might
reduce the credibility of an argument
but that's really uh up to the
marketplace of ideas that it it's up to
the listener to or the reader to decide
how much do how much credibility do we
want to invest in what this particular
person is saying and it's kind of nice
i'm a libertarian i like having choices
so it's kind of nice to have the choice
of either going with okay here i'm
bringing the accrued whatever you know
the the crude currency and value of my
reputation to bear by signing my name or
i'm going to publish it anonymously so
maybe people will take it in a different
way were there trolls or can you talk
about you know when i think well i think
what a lot of people think about
anonymous speech on the internet right
now you know it's always like you know
uh
power glute 69 or you know i remember uh
mark foley a barely remembered
congressman who was largely responsible
for giving the democrats the uh the
majority of congress in 2006 because he
was involved in a sex scandal his aol
instant messenger handle was math 54.
um you know but are there um you know
were there good troll names back in the
days of uh you know kind of a
pseudonymous journalism
they were different uh there were
they the names themselves um some of
some of them were very colorful
perhaps not as explicit as some of the
more modern
pseudonyms online but uh there
definitely were trolls i
i start the book actually with someone i
refer to as the og troll which is junius
in england i mean he was a great troll
he and to this day we don't have a
definitive consensus as to who he is
there's some a lot of speculation as to
one person but he basically trolled the
king he
trolled the prime minister until he
resigned
and he was very effective and when
when i read a lot of these days about
how
civility with online speech has gone
down the toilet and how we've never or
cable news or whatever the panic of the
day is
i've spent so much of the past few years
immersed in things like juniors and
these colonial newspapers which
uh were better written but also
were just far more cutting than
than what you typically see online today
so i don't necessarily think that
trolling or
a lack of civility is a new trend
yeah um so you know we
you know to the extent that people learn
about the federalist papers outside of
uh you know law school or something like
that we know this was great because they
were you know they were important and
they made arguments in order to justify
the ratification of the constitution i
realized there's an academic debate
about their actual effectiveness in that
but
everybody loves an anonymous
truth-teller when they kind of agree
with the truth that that peop those
people are telling um
what in 19th century america you know we
we get through the revolution the
constitution said even the you know the
war of 1812 um what was the what was the
attitude to the people in power
towards anonymous speech or pseudonymous
speech were they like well you know what
this is part of being an american so
we're going to put up with it or were
they constantly trying to clip it and
unmask people and punish them
there was in the 19th century there
wasn't as much of of an attempt to
unmask people it was more actually more
just uh
focused on
bringing things like sedition charges
against um against publishers of
newspapers even even if some of the
things they published were anonymous
there there were varying reactions to it
but
uh it really
it was all it was so prevalent that the
idea of pseudonymous speech at the time
and
someone who's actually captured it
probably better than anyone else that
i've read has been justice thomas
because he is an originalist when he
looks at whether we have a right to
anonymous speech and this is where he
differed sharply from justice scalia he
um
he did in a few opinions very thorough
analyses of what it was like in
at the time of the nation's founding in
terms of anonymous speech and he said it
was so prevalent that you can't read
freedom of the press
and not think that part of that freedom
is the freedom to be anonymous because
it was just all over the place at the
time
uh yeah uh justice thomas clarence
thomas is kind of one of the heroes of
this book i have no idea you know how
you feel about his overall jurisprudence
but he is remarkably good on this
question of uh
of
giving a right to or insisting on rights
to anonymous speech where is that coming
from his originalism
does it come from
you know one of the one of the themes
that goes through this book and you talk
about cases where the naacp among others
pushed to have their membership
committees or their membership roles
kept secret um partly because you know
being
being outed in alabama you know
basically anytime until relatively
recently that was kind of like a if not
a death warrant it was you know it puts
you under attack um is that is does that
inform thomas's uh appreciation for
anonymity do you think
no that informed the liberal justices
with whom he joined and to form
majorities that informed their views uh
in terms of the benefits of
being anonymous they they really
looked at why what what the virtues of
anonymity are
justice thomas would write separately
and say i agree with the outcome
but all of this is nonsense that's not
what we look at what we look at is what
did freedom of freedom of speech and of
the press mean
at the time the constitution was written
and that's all we look at and
justice scalia who took the same
approach to constitutional
interpretation
applied that same framework but he came
out entirely differently and he he said
no there's nothing
about being anonymous in
in the first amendment and i so so they
they both applied originalism but came
to a different conclusion justice scalia
he
also in some of his writings it was very
clear that he just had a real distaste
for anonymous speech and
he he didn't see much value in why
anyone would want to be anonymous but
for justice thomas he said you know that
that makes no difference what i care
about
is what these words mean and i i can't
see how it wouldn't mean
anonymity um you spend a lot of time
talking about uh two cases tally v
california and mcintyre versus ohio
board of elections uh which helped to
establish the right to distribute
anonymous speech in specifically
political context and this is always
amazing you know i i
i don't know you know i guess i as as
much as one can be a free speech
absolutist i i you know i am i don't
think that commercial speech or artistic
speech should be accorded less freedom
than political speech and i realize all
these categories are kind of hard to
disentangle but a lot of people for i
mean for most of the uh you know most of
the existence of the us people were
willing to say well commercial speech is
not as protected as political speech but
um talley v california mcintyre v board
of the ohio board of elections are
specifically about polit anonymous
political speech in a political context
can you talk about them and why they are
so important
sure so the cali case it was a little
broader
um because for cali it was uh in 1960 or
the the events happened in 1958 i
believe
where uh there was a man emmanuel talley
who was a fairly prominent civil rights
activist in los angeles and he was
distributing
hand bills outside of a grocery store in
los angeles urging a boycott
because
he said that grocery store
purchased goods from
companies that discriminated in their
employment practices so
there was a long list of the types of
products that
were that he believed were
purchased from these companies and uh at
the bottom of the pamphlet he listed his
group's name
and address but it did not have his name
on it and there was an ordinance at the
time in los angeles
that was not just restricted to
political pamphlets it said for any
pamphlet that's hell or hand bill that's
handed out in public you need to list
the author
of the handbill
and interestingly that grocery store
also handed out hand bills
at the same corner and they did not list
the author of their hand bill but
only one of them got
fined and charged by the lapd and of
course that was manual tally he
challenges this
all the way it's a ten dollar fine he
challenges it all the way up to the
supreme court
and the supreme court in a six to three
decision
says that this ordinance is facially
unconstitutional because
we have this long-standing tradition of
anonymous speech going back to the
federalist papers to thomas paine to
junius
and we
and by
imposing an identification requirement
you are effectively censoring and
chilling a wide swath of speech was that
the
you know is is it fair to say that was
the intention of the ordinance
it's not clear there the record was i i
was able to get actually his trial
transcript but it was at a municipal
court and the judge basically just said
i'm gonna have to throw it up to the
higher courts i'm not qualified to
make these sorts of judgments so um it's
really that that wasn't
as much argued but i mean it clearly was
not uniformly enforced because you had
stores that
were handing out these flyers without
people's names but when you have a civil
rights
activist
then he gets cited for a violation so at
least in enforcement there's some
problems yeah and then uh what about
mcintyre the ohio board of elections
this this was settled in 1995 and uh
for the old timers out there this i
wrote about this a couple years into
starting market reason
and i remember just being gobsmacked
that this could even be a
a case because the facts of it seem so
ridiculous uh would you explain you know
what mcintyre uh versus ohio board of
elections uh sure so margaret mcintyre
she lived in a
suburban town in ohio and
she very much disagreed with a proposal
for a school referendum that would
increase taxes so she made photocopies
of flyers that she was going to hand out
at various school board meetings
explaining why the
why why the tax was unfair and why
people should vote no
and
there was an ohio law at the time that
said you needed to include the name of
the author of a hand bill if it's
involving any sort of ballot initiative
or any anything political something
actually political it's like yeah yeah
yeah so it was restricted it was
something enforced by the ohio elections
commission so porn porn could be
anonymous
or you know but not a bill saying like
don't vote for this school board
increase yeah with the idea that the
justification is that we want to inform
voters and we don't want all sorts of
confusion about who is sending a message
out right and she actually tries to
comply with it and she puts her name on
the handles but she made photocopies and
some of the photocopies cut off her name
so she they weren't on some of them now
unfortunately
one of the handles that she was handing
out
at a school board meeting
was spotted by the assistant
superintendent of schools who very much
opposed her saying that they didn't want
to she didn't want people to raise taxes
for the schools
so he report he he sees this flyer
doesn't have her name on it he reports
her to the ohio elections commission
and they hold a hearing and they issue a
fine and
she very much
she wants to take up the cause that this
requirement is unconstitutional based on
manual tally
and other supreme court precedent like
the naacp cases you talked about so
she challenges this and it goes through
three different court systems in ohio it
gets
reversed and then
affirmed and it ends up going to the
supreme court the u.s supreme court she
dies in the interim but the supreme
court lets her husband
take up the case for her
and the supreme court finds that for
many of the same reasons in
that emanuel tally won his case that
margaret margaret mcintyre also wins her
case because this law
is unconstitutional and
what the and the court better clarifies
the right to anonymous speech that it's
not absolute they
apply a standard called exacting
scrutiny which has had some controversy
over the years because it's kind of like
oh we'll just make up we'll have a
standard that's kind of like strict
scrutiny but not really
um
and
but but justice ginsburg writes
separately to say
she agrees that it's unconstitutional
but she says well
there might be some circumstances in the
future where
this right does not uh
does not
overcome the real needs of the
government
and uh justice thomas actually writes
separately this is his most extensive
writing on anonymous speech where he
concurs but
he basically argues for much stronger
protections and he says you know this is
what i how i see the first amendment
reading and it shouldn't be this weird
societal balancing test it should be
we have a right to speak anonymously and
that that really helps to reaffirm
the tally precedent and
really emphasize that even in a
political context
we have a right to be anonymous now
justice ginsburg's caution i think was
basically
left the door open for what the court
would do over the next 15 or so years
which would be in a number of campaign
finance related cases even in a case
like citizens united which expanded the
uh
the ability of
for expenditures they they did affirm a
number in uh citizens united in the
mcconnell case
involving mccain feingold
the supreme court did affirm the ability
for the government to impose campaign
finance disclosure requirements and
justifies
yeah that's why at the end of every ad
whoever is doing it they they either
have to say who it is or if it's a
candidate they have to say that they
endorse this uh
you know this statement or whatever yes
and for expenditures and disclosures and
donations and justice thomas has in a
number of these cases has dissented and
he's said you know that this is not
consistent
with what we said in the mcintyre case
and
i i think he has a point
i think it is difficult to reconcile
yeah how do you feel about that because
a big part of the the power of or the
argument for anonymity is that when you
are speaking truth to power
you you know you are putting yourself
out there and being anonymous gives you
protection not necessarily to speak you
know untruths but rather so that you
will actually engage in speech i know
there was a case i guess this was in the
90s i believe in california where a
couple of
people decided to try and unseat the
speaker the the
california state senate i believe
they were total uh rubes when it came to
organizing a political campaign so they
did not file a bunch of laws like where
you have to have disclosure and you have
to have a an address and you you know
and uh you know of the people who give
because it's got to come from a certain
area and things like that they did not
recall the politician they wanted they
failed and then they got slammed with
the highest fines
in california state history for election
uh problems i mean that kind of
exemplifies why you don't really want
disclosure laws right yeah
and i i think they're i think that's
right and i also think that
in a case that went up to
the supreme court about a decade ago
again where justice thomas dissented
over the majority where they they said
that you can allow the disclosure the
public disclosure of people who sign
ballot referendum right petitions how do
you feel about that
i mean i see the arguments on both sides
for it i i do feel that i do worry that
it has a chilling effect because even
signing i think does have an expressive
component and i i worry that
particularly for controversial
issues where someone might have
ramifications on their employment i i
think that there are valid reasons
for that so i think that's a closer call
yeah but it's also true and you know i i
think i can argue this either way that
it's also true if you sign something
that is kind of a public statement and
um you know why shouldn't we know who's
you know who supports something or who
doesn't i know there was the big case
and this is going back years now
uh brendan ike who was a a programmer
who was involved with mozilla the
mozilla firefox foundation
he was named the head of mozilla firefox
for about 15 minutes until it came out
that he had signed an anti-gay marriage
proposition and he got cashiered and
it's kind of an interesting question
right because should he i guess there's
many questions there should should he be
able to do that anonymously but then
it's also like if you're counting
signatures in order to get something on
the ballot they have to be valid
signature so you need to know who signed
it so you can check them but then you
know the question of can it be made
public it's probably gonna be right just
because we're in an age of force
transparency to begin with and then
finally there's that larger question of
let's say he did it everybody knows it
should should people get fired for that
kind of stuff that's also a kind of
thorny issue as well
sure
um what about uh you know let's uh talk
a little bit about um the right to
anonymous association um because you
know the the naacp
sued the state of alabama to keep its
list of members or donors secret and
uh did they won that right
yeah so so that was a case where this
was sort of right in the few years after
brown versus board of education you had
the naacp working in alabama
very vigorously and
amid a tremendous number of obstacles to
desegregate schools and implement other
civil rights measures and not
surprisingly a number of alabama state
officials very much opposed all of the
naacp's efforts and
there was a segregationist attorney
general who went on to become governor
and he
thought he found a way to basically shut
down the naacp and that was that they
had not complied with this pretty arcane
corporation registration requirement for
the state
the naacp didn't think that they needed
to because they were not based in
alabama but they in fact did an easy an
easy way to solve this would be to have
them fill out the proper paperwork and
maybe pay a small fine
but alabama sued
the naacp to get them to
shut shut down their operations
and then on top of that
as part of the discovery in this case
the state requested a membership list of
everyone in alabama who's an naacp
member which is completely irrelevant to
whether they registered as a corporation
but
unfortunately the
judge in the case
was in name a man named walter jones who
actually also was the trial court judge
in new york times verse sullivan and he
was a white supremacist he wrote and i'm
not using that term lightly he wrote
newspaper columns
titled i speak for the white race and so
he
also very much did not want the naacp to
be operating and so he both
temper temporarily ordered naacp to shut
down its operations in the state and
also required the naacp to give provide
its membership list and the naacp went
to the supreme court they tried the
alabama supreme court but not
surprisingly that
did not help them very much so they go
to the u.s supreme court and they said
that there's a right to associate
anonymously and they gave very good
reasons of saying there's
actual evidence that members will have
threats to their safety if we just give
the state
a list of everyone who's a member
and the us supreme court unanimously
found that there is this right to
associate and part of that free in the
first amendment and part of that freedom
of association
is the freedom to associate anonymously
and
uh this was really the first case
where the supreme court this was two
years before tally's case so this was
the first case where the supreme court
really recognized a strong right to be
anonymous
you also write about cases though where
it you know that becomes inverted and
it's ku klux klan or you know
white supremacist groups that are now
suing to keep their list secret um or or
to be able to associate anonymously
had you know it seems like from a
principal point of view it's like you
you gotta go
yeah you know like you you don't you
don't have to
um you know you the the state should
never be able i guess on except for if
they have a criminal warrant or a
warrant that has gone through a legal
procedure uh where that information is
necessary people shouldn't really have
to you know divulge membership lists is
that accurate
well so the courts have come out both
ways there have been a number of cases
involving the ku klux klan and this is
because a number of state and local
governments have passed anti-mass clause
nothing having to do with the kovid
debate right
about 100 years old a lot of these laws
some even more that say you can't wear a
mask to conceal your identity in a
public place
they vary in what they actually require
but some judges have looked at these
laws and said no they've they're
violations of the right to be anonymous
and i i've i read through the records of
a number of these cases a lot of them
were in the 90s
and there was something pretty chilling
about the ku klux klan citing precedent
that the naacp
created
but then what really struck me and this
really
stayed with me more than
most of the other things that i found in
the book was
there was a case involving a regulation
that giuliani's nypd when he was mayor
in the late 90s
tried to enforce an anti-mask law where
he they basically tried to get the clan
to not do a rally in new york by saying
we're going to enforce our anti-mask law
and the klan challenged this
kind of in a last-minute proceeding
and
there
and so i was able to find all the briefs
that were filed in it i was looking
through
and i saw a national action network
which is al sharpton's group and
i just immediately assumed that this
would be something saying we don't want
the ku klux klan to come to new york
because that would be logical right the
ku klux klan is kind of antithetical to
everything that al sharpton stands for
but al sharpton's brief it's actually a
very
very very
um
powerful brief that
says we detest everything the clan
stands for
but we support them in this case
because if you're able to
violate their first amendment rights
and such a fundamental rate you'll also
be able to violate our first amendment
rights
and i found that such an intellectually
honest and powerful
statement and i i'd imagine that at the
time it was
perhaps not the most politically popular
stance for him to take but i i think
that really demonstrated the power
of anonymous speech
for
groups that otherwise wouldn't have a
voice that he that he would go to those
lengths to
side with the ku klux klan in that case
are there you know uh part of the book
talks about a you know from a legal
perspective of you know no virtually no
right is absolute so there is always
some kind of balancing act going on
um
do you think that things like
anti-masking laws
do they ever serve a useful function
that you would say yeah yeah we really
shouldn't allow
this kind of event or this group of
people to be able to show up
covering their you know their identity
yeah i mean i i think that it really
depends and i i think that there there
are good arguments even for anti-mass
flaws that the the the police in the
giuliani case they said you know it
makes it really difficult to
maintain public order when you have
people running around in masks you can't
see who they are
i don't think they provided enough
evidence that this difficulty overcame
the right to be anonymous but there are
valid justifications uh it's not all
just sort of like 1950s alabama state
officials who are trying to suppress the
naacp i mean there's
offline and especially when you get to
online there are some very valid reasons
why
you would need to unmask someone yeah
and uh well let's let's uh kind of talk
about online stuff because that seems to
be where
uh you know most of the worst kind of
speech
you know where speech is much more
likely to be anonymous or pseudonymous
or harder to track
but also where a lot of the most intense
stuff is going on
what are the what are the decisions uh
governing anonymity in terms of comments
and user identities online and how uh if
you could start with the earlier days
you talk a lot about like yahoo finance
message boards which
uh at one time could you know could make
or break companies this moved markets
the yahoo finance boards um not so much
anymore but what was going on there that
is you know really kind of paradigmatic
about the issue of anonymous speech and
anonymous
association
yeah it's hard to even
state how influential the yahoo finance
boards were and i was i had started as a
business journalist in 2001 so i kind of
caught the talent of this but it really
started in the mid to late 90s when
yahoo finance set up and they had a
bulletin board for pretty much every
publicly traded company and people could
go on and create a pseudonym yahoo would
ask for your email address but
it didn't have to be a real one and they
would log your ip address which is a
unique string of numbers associated with
your internet connection yeah and it
kind of it's kind of an identifier but
it's not you know it's it's about as
good as a social security number in the
sense that it it you know can be forged
or it can be very inexact about linking
to the particular person who speaks yeah
i mean i i can tell you right now if i
go and look at my my available wi-fi
connections in my house
i see some neighbors who have unsecured
wi-fi connections which i think is
insane in this day and age but uh you
know but it used to be that used to be
considered good etiquette right everyone
networking first came after you were
only dicks like would secure their
network because the idea was that you
know the the the traveling hobo is gonna
need a an internet hookup but yeah um
yeah so so
that's what yahoo would collect and
the reason why yahoo was so
influential at the time was because
corporate executives are pretty thin
skinned and
i think you're going to need some
citations for that
well i i can say from my time as a
business reporter that corporate
executives are very thin
but when i would write an article about
them
they would usually my editor got tired
of getting complaints from the
executives but they knew who to call and
they knew who to get angry at
but yahoo finance was different because
they would get much more cutting
criticism
[Music]
a lot of it is very informed some of it
is pretty clear that it's coming or a
lot of it was pretty clear that it was
coming from people who worked at the
companies
and what was maddening to them is they
didn't know who was doing it
and they because and they weren't used
to that sort of criticism they were used
to
just operating their business and
employees would stay in line but now
their employees were going on the
internet and broadcasting to the world
why the company was not properly
functioning
so
the company the executives
at a lot of these companies from big and
small from small startups all the way up
to raytheon
what they started doing in the late 90s
and early 2000s was they would
try to use the legal system to figure
out who these people were so it was a
multi-step process they would first have
to file a lawsuit it was typically
some pretty weak defamation lawsuit or
a lawsuit alleging that these employees
violated their confidentiality agreement
something like that
although
even without knowing for sure that it
was one of their employees so yeah
that's part of the reason why it's so
weak to say you violated an agreement
that we think you signed right we don't
know if you signed it because we don't
know who you are
um and they would then they'd file it
against john doe's one to twenty and
sometimes they'd file it under against
the their often pretty bizarre usernames
and then as part of the early discovery
in the case
they would issue a subpoena first to
yahoo and say we want every all the
information you have about these posters
and some of the times yahoo would be and
yahoo at first they did not
give any notification to the users that
their
information was subpoenaed there was no
requirement for them to do it
uh so they would yahoo would typically
at first just turn over the information
and it usually wouldn't be their names
but it in many cases it was their email
address which contained their names
but other times it was just some weird
some uh really indecipherable email
address but they'd at least have the ip
address
and then
if they only had the ip address then the
company would be they could tell what
isp was associated with that i p address
and they'd issue a second subpoena to
the isp saying we want the subscriber
name
and this was before people had wi-fi so
it was usually pretty effective i mean
tor wasn't around nothing like that so
it was pretty effective at identifying
people
the companies would then
usually it was employees if it was an
employee they'd fire them
and then they would dismiss the case
and that's how our legal system was
being used and
what you started having were there was
more coverage of these sorts of cases
over the over a few years and you
started to have
people at privacy advocacy groups the
electronic frontier foundation
paul levy at public citizen was
one of the most active and he helped set
the standard that started either filing
amicus briefs or representing these
defendants because soon enough um
yahoo started giving notice to the
people because it got a lot of public
criticism right that it wasn't giving
people the opportunity to challenge so
they would start moving to cost the
subpoenas and what you had by 2003 to
2005
was a variety of different standards the
courts would
apply all based on tally and mcintyre
and this first amendment right to
anonymous speech
and the standards vary but what they
basically say is if you're going to
unmask someone in this sort of
defamation or
confidentiality case
you need to fulfill a number of
procedural requirements like trying to
notify people
get their identity through other means
but also and most importantly you have
to have a strong case and they use
different legal terms of how to get
there but that you can't just say we
think they violated a confidentiality
agreement or we think they defamed us
but you need to show evidence of all of
the elements
of defamation
and what this has done what would those
be beyond saying you know raytheon stock
is going to tank because of this that
and the other reason and the you know
the
administrators there the executives
there are idiots
well so it would depend on the k if it
was a defamation case you would have to
show you'd have to
show falsity and you would have to show
damages you'd have to show that it was
oven concerning you so
yeah and you it's not enough to get
discovery in these sorts of cases
because it involves anonymous speech
you have to do more than you would in a
typical subpoena which is pretty much
rubber stamped
and the
and what this did is this created a
barrier which is not absolute so i mean
there are cases
where particularly involving harassment
or really persistent defamation of
individuals where
the
subpoenas are
approved by the courts and i think it's
largely struck the right balance
in these sorts of cases like defamation
where unfortunately it's really fairly
limited to defamation confidentiality
agreements those sorts of cases
what we had in parallel happening in the
early 2000s was
were a number of copyright related cases
where
if you remember the recording industry
had the idea that
because people were using peer-to-peer
services they would just start suing
people and part of that lawsuit was
issuing subpoenas to identify them right
and the courts basically through those
cases found
that there was some first amendment
protection for these peer-to-peer cases
but not as much because
copyright is that they said you know
copyright is not first amendment
protected i i disagree with how they
reasoned it because
there's no
we haven't
determined copyright infringement
happened we haven't determined these are
the people but they basically came up
with a compromise that's a much lower
standard
the big problem is that
over the past 10 years this standard has
been used not as much with
music but with uh
pornographic pornography companies legal
pornography
but uh pornography that's traded on
peer-to-peer networks uh the owners of
those copyrights sue
and
they use they're able to use the same
standard which is pretty low
and it effectively one judge said that
it was like an extortion scheme because
basically you're
you have the choice of you know do you
settle
or do you risk being named in a lawsuit
that your friends your family most
importantly your employer could see that
you've downloaded this particular
pornographic movie and for some people
their employers won't care but for some
people that could mean
that their jobs are on the line so that
i i think that that's one area and the
other area is criminal and grand jury
cases we don't have very much case law
because it's usually pretty hard to
challenge a grand jury subpoena
for
from the target because they're not
going to be aware of it
but the case law that we do have has
largely indicated that it's a much lower
standard and that's a problem to me
because
as as troubling as it is in the civil
context in the criminal or grand jury
context you have the prospect of
someone's liberty possibly being at
stake and i think we need to really
rethink that could you talk about how
this
these kinds of cases intersect with
section 230. i mean one of the reasons
um raytheon
couldn't sue yahoo itself that's because
of 230 right
yeah so section 230 the basic
justification up for it is
that you can sue the person who posted
but not the platform where they posted
it because the the
the
you know the the owner of an interactive
computer service you know yahoo uh yelp
whatever will not be seen as the
publisher of that of user generated
material yeah exactly so
that that's where it intersects but
the
issue becomes what if the person is
anonymous and you can't track them down
right uh then
you because it's not just the legal
protections i include a chapter in the
book about horror
um people using multiple vpns which
aren't as anonymous someone could use
their neighbors wifi connection there's
ways to
anonymize at least temporarily where
there are
there is a potential
for not
having a remedy
and and
where this really intersects with 230
and i write about this in the book is
that
um
this is more for
not as much about mainstream platforms
but they're i i'd encourage everyone to
read cashmere hills reporting in the new
york times about slander sites that
basically
exist and they have a strict policy
which they can have because of section
230 of not taking down
content uh
including content that calls
it's not just normal insults it's things
that accuse people of doing horrific
things that can really ruin their lives
and um the they both they
the idea is that you know you could sue
the person who posted it right uh and
oftentimes that person's anonymous
sometimes they're not
but if you sue and you get an
adjudication
that
the
content was defamatory so it's not
constitutionally protected
um you still at least
according to the california supreme
court in a case that did involve yelp um
that section 230 prevents an order in
the case between the poster and the and
and the subject
from requiring the site to take down the
content that's adjudicated to be
defamatory and there are valid reasons
for for example people forge court
orders which i think is a problem that
people are forging court orders right um
also that often these cases if the
anonymous poster doesn't show up they
just become default judgments so the
person that there might not be a really
vigorous adversarial
argument about whether this content was
actually defamatory
but there does become a problem where
you could have someone something that's
posted anonymously that a court
determines his defamatory
um and you still can't get it taken down
and that that's one area where it sort
of intersects with 230.
when you were talking about quashing um
subpoenas
um how do how do you do it say raytheon
to go back to them um
uh you know like they see something on a
yahoo finance board or on on a bulletin
board or in a comment section and they
they you know then they subpoena a
particular commenter who they believe or
a person they believe is that commenter
what are the grounds that the commenter
can quash the uh subpoena
well so now because of the precedent
that folks like paul levy at public
citizens at it's first amendment grounds
they say that the this
this subpoena is
not
the complaint
under which the subpoena was issued does
not allege let's say a viable defamation
claim there's no and
this wasn't defamatory by any legal
standard or there's not sufficient
evidence to support it so this violates
the first amendment right to anonymous
speech and then
the company would then
file an
opposition saying you know this is all
of our evidence this is our argument and
then it would be up to the judge to
decide whether
the plaintiff has demonstrated
sufficient evidence and other met other
burdens
to allow the identifying information to
be released are there reasons to believe
that corporations or you know or that
there are more of these suits now than
there were or haves corporate america or
you know and and also groups and whatnot
have they gotten you know
are they like we're not going to do
something that's going to bring more
attention we're not going to we're not
going to
uh you know uh consciously enact a
streisand effect where we're gonna bring
more attention to something
that um you know nobody's paying
attention to is it is it ramping up is
it or have we kind of settled into a a
kind of pattern where you know people
recognize look anonymous trollish
comments in various places nobody takes
them that seriously precisely because
they are anonymous and trollish so
there's kind of a social check on the
influence of
anonymous speech
so it's hard to tell with any sort of
statistical certainty because there's no
official tally of these sorts of cases
i'd say there are fewer published court
opinions over the past five years or so
than there were
in
let's say the mid to
late auths
and
and i i mean i i think that there might
be a few reasons for this uh
in part companies might be getting
slightly thicker skins uh this was all
very new to them
in the late 90s that they would actually
get criticized by lowly employees who
would
dare to criticize these brilliant
examples if i re maybe miss remembering
this but in the early days uh i'm
thinking in the early to mid 90s when a
bunch of sites started doing things like
raiding doctors and lawyers
there was pushback you know like now how
dare you do that and there were attempts
to ban those kinds of sites in the name
of you know professional etiquette of
doctors and lawyers and now
that seems to have faded because people
recognize that
you you need to promote a good
reputation online so instead of trying
to control people you just try to make
sure that they have a better experience
with you yeah i i think that's right and
i i think the streisand effect does play
into that
in that if you're going to sue an
anonymous commenter now
you're very likely at the very least
going to have a courthouse news and a
law 360 article written about you so
then when people google your medical
practice or your illegal practice one of
the first things that comes up is that
you've sued your customers right and
i think that does play into it but i i
don't want to minimize that this is this
is still going on yeah yeah so i mean i
write about glass i started out the book
writing that glassdoor and glassdoor
actually should really be commended
because
they it's a site where people post
reviews of employers and
they actually really they not only
notify people but they actually
stand in the shoes of the posters and
file their own challenges to these
subpoenas and if as you can imagine
glassdoor gets tons of these subpoenas
because they're basically saying this is
the home for people to write candid
reviews about employers so
it definitely is still happening
yeah um could you uh briefly uh for
people who might not uh know it or know
the nuances of what is
what is the streisand effect and where
did it come from and i say this also
partly because any chance i get to kind
of make fun of barbra streisand i'm
going to take it uh but
explain the streisand effect so the
stress streisand effect it was um
it was uh barbara streisand i think it
was 2005 i believe
uh was trying to get a
photo taken down of i believe it was her
home an unflattering photo of her home
uh and so she filed a very weak yeah
that was part of uh that was part of a
uh like the california coastal
commission or something had yeah aerial
photographs of of all these kinds of
houses in a database because that was
part of what they were doing yeah
and so she she filed
uh
she she filed a lawsuit and um and
that drew a lot more attention right to
to this issue and so mike maznick
attacked her
he wrote about this and he called it the
streisand effect
because
that it was her efforts to
um be treated differently or to to
stop a conversation you know which
wasn't even happening because there was
something like there were dozens of
downloads of the aerial photograph of
her property
before but that was too much for her to
bear and then after she made a big stink
about it
hundreds of thousands of people looked
at it
and i i mean i'll say the streisand
effect does work in the opposite way so
for people who
i and i mean i've spoke i spoke for this
book in my previous book i spoke with a
lot of people who were
have really had awful things happen to
them online and really awful defamatory
things that i mean and i don't call
things defamatory lightly but these are
defamatory
and they choose not to do something
about it not to file a lawsuit
because even though it's making it hard
to get a job
they know that if they filed a lawsuit
that this would create even more
attention to it so
uh it it does work in both ways even if
it's things that you really think
you know should should be taken down um
yeah would you you in one part of the
book uh you talk about online anonymity
as a shield and i think we've kind of
covered that why you know having being
able to post anonymously or
pseudonymously gives people the ability
to enter conversations they might not
otherwise and actually share information
which will then be evaluated based on
you know kind of the way it's presented
and and taking into account the fact
that it's anonymous right but you also
talk about online anonymity as a sword
and you spend a fair amount of time
talking about a character named ryan lin
who is kind of like the uh
the michael jordan of cyber stalkers who
was this guy and how does he show
the real negative potential or negative
realization of online anonymity
so ryan lynn
he was
in his mid-20s he had a computer science
degree and he was living in a house in
massachusetts
with three other people who were also in
their 20s and
he he was only there for about a month
and he got into
a dispute with one of the women there
and
over various issues and she had left her
computer
unlocked and it had all of her online
passwords
so before
before he moved out he was able to get
access to all of her accounts and from
those passwords
and basically for months after he
engaged in
a very extensive
harassment and cyber stalking campaign
not only involving her but involving her
parents
her co-workers other people
um she where where it was he found for
example uh her online diary where she
had written about having an abortion and
some intimate photos of her and he
basically created a collage of these
photos along with other photos he found
not of her
and he
he would email it to her parents
co-workers to her co-workers
he would use torah and other anonymizing
technologies
sometimes you would make it look like it
was coming from her
and
he would sign her
up on bondage sites and
he
would he called in
bomb threats to her home he actually
called in more than 100 bomb threats
throughout the area which anonymously
that
caused real disruptions for local
schools
um
he he did
it was persistent and it it really
ruined her life uh her parents were
worried about their security
and she she knew that it was him
but there's a difference between knowing
that it's him and having enough evidence
to be able to prosecute someone so she
went to the police the local police and
they really wanted to help her this one
local police officer actually took
computer classes to try to figure out
how to
how how to be able to unmask him but
they they really weren't able to do it
and i think that that really revealed
and i i've heard the story so many times
the real um
lack of investment that we have in cyber
crime that we don't
and a lot of law enforcement we don't
take it as seriously as non-internet
related crimes
but fortunately aft after a long time
she a friend of a friend knew
someone who a lawyer who i'm good
friends with named carrie goldberg and
she
has a law firm that basically
specializes in
representing people who are the victims
of online crimes and kerry was able to
work with
her contacts of the fbi
fortunately because
they were interested in it both because
of the bomb threats and also because
some of the materials that he sent
contained child sex abuse material and
so that gave a federal jurisdictional
hook which really very well could there
could not have been in which case
they might not have been able to help
um so they're able to finally they were
able to finally track him down because
he logged on to
two different email accounts on the same
vpn and this vpn apparently kept logs
so
the v so they're able to finally uh
arrest him
and he pleads guilty and he gets
sentenced to 17 and a half years in
prison
and um
it's i i've spoken with the woman who
was his main target
and i've read through the entire very
extensive court record and
it really um
demonstrates how someone can use
anonymity tools even when you're not
fully
anonymous even when people
many people might know who you are think
they know who you are
but um
it showed both how someone could use
them to devastate people but it also
shows that even someone who
has a computer science degree and is
taking all of these steps even he can
eventually be unmasked but
the problem is that he's unmasked after
months of causing these tremendous harms
this is uh kind of the brave new world
right where i think about this in
connection to uh when the silk road case
in the early teens kind of started
bubbling up and people had been confused
and thought that bitcoin was
anonymous that you know you wouldn't
know who was using it and it turns out
bitcoin
facilitates a lot of activity that
otherwise wouldn't be taking place but
it's not quite anonymous i mean online
anonymity
it's there but it's all you know we're
it you know nobody is quite uh
uh nobody's quite invisible right it
seems like and as we develop these
technologies and become more comfortable
with them that's probably going to
become more and more the case where
if we may just briefly talk about aol
um you know because aol now to the
extent that it exists anymore it's you
know it's like the edsel of of isps or
something nobody wants to take it
seriously but it was the largest isp for
a long time and part of its pull was
that you didn't have to use your real
name um
who came up with that and um you know
how did that how did that help aol
really gain a lot of market share at a
certain point in time
well so you know i'm not as familiar
with aol's business model i know steve
case uh i at least from the people the
lawyers i spoke with who worked at
aol steve case he actually was they say
was very passionate
about defending people whose information
was subpoenaed so i mean there there
were a lot of times that aol did have
identifying information about people
because if they were paying
with a credit card and they would then
there were there was a way to trace
people yeah but what aol really did
was they they went to court a lot i was
actually kind of like what glassdoor
does now and they would notify people
if they were the targets of
subpoenas uh because they
they really saw privacy as a selling
point yeah for their service so it's a
bit different than
what we now see
for big tech companies but
um but but that that was really one of
their features
yeah um so you were a journalist let's
let's talk a little bit about how you
ended up becoming a law professor um but
um you know
when were you born where were you born
where did you grow up
well so i was born in uh upstate
watertown new york in 1978 uh but the uh
the the subject of frank sinatra's
greatest and possibly only concept album
uh but i i don't remember it i grew up
in new jersey and central new jersey all
right well century now you're just
trolling me because i am from central
jersey and i often say the only people
who even acknowledge central jersey as a
region are people from central jersey
because there is a central jersey i
agree what town were you uh raised from
east brunswick oh okay very nice i went
to rucker so i know east brunswick will
call from that and the stuff your face
there on red 18. yes i grew up in
middletown uh new jersey which is on the
eastern edge of central jersey so you
you grow up in new jersey so that means
that you're a malcontent and you have an
attitude problem
pretty much where do you go next
i went to college at the university of
michigan okay that's a problem but okay
because i lived in ohio but i had i
don't want to make this about me but
yeah
um so
yeah
so yeah after that i i had intern i
i kind i i'd say i went to college i got
a degree from the university of michigan
i sometimes went to class but most of my
time i spent at the college newspaper
the michigan daily
um so that's where i was probably there
much more and so i did journalism
internships and
uh one of the summers i interned at the
oregonian in portland and so i was out
there for a summer when it's nice and
sunny and they miraculously offered me a
job this was kind of at the beginning of
the tech boom they needed another tech
reporter so they said when you graduate
come back and i was like oh this is
great portland's always sunny um and i
came back and i learned that portland
was not sunny but i was in portland for
a few years covering technology and
doing investigative work um at the time
what were you uh what was the uh you
were a finalist for pulitzer prize what
was that about yeah so that i actually
after i i moved out to dc
after a few years in portland and i
covered congress for the oregonian but
also did investigative work
this was for a program
that's now changed its name but it was
called javits wagner o'day
it was started in the 1970s a federal
program that basically set aside some
federal contracts for sheltered
workshops and the and the requirement
was that 75 of their
work had to be performed by people with
severe disabilities and it was always
they would make like notepads and
pencils for a long time uh then we went
to iraq and afghanistan and the program
grew from a few million dollars a year
to billions of dollars a year
and what we found was um more
more than 10 percent of the entire
program was going to one place
in el paso texas that was
making a lot of chemical water fair
suits
for the military
and this is
we were curious about i'm sorry that is
so dark um
yeah
it was so so what we found and they they
employed
they said they employed about 4 000
people with severe disabilities
which seem like you know that that's a
lot of people because
the criteria for severe disabilities was
quite high
but what we found after months of
investigating and me spending far too
much time in el paso texas
and i'll add the ceo he
had a consulting firm that the nonprofit
paid millions of dollars to he had a
private jet company that the non-profit
paid uh for his private charter jet
and he was one of the most well
connected people in town
um and what we found was that there
they were counting anyone who speaks
english as a second language as be
having a severe disability in el paso
um so the day that our stories ran we
did a whole series um actually steve
engelberg who's now the
editor of propublica he was the managing
editor on the project uh i learned a ton
from him on that
the day the stories ran the fbi raided
the non-profit
the executive i think he's out of prison
now but he
uh was sentenced to quite a bit of
prison time
but we relied actually quite a bit on
anonymous sources and we dealt with a
lot of legal threats uh throughout that
case so that really
shaped my
um
interest in free speech because i mean i
i remember getting claims from lawyers
saying you know this is violating the
texas penal code and i remember
calling steve engelberg and saying does
this mean that i go to jail in texas i
don't really want to go to jail in texas
uh but i i think central new jersey you
could live with i think the railway
state prison is technically in central
jersey texas is different yeah yeah
so anyway that that really sort of made
me
appreciate and we we had great lawyers
and they really
uh did everything great for us so when i
was practicing law before i went into
academia one of the my favorite things
to do was doing pre-publication review
work for media companies because i
remember just sort of
how important that sort of work is to
helping get stories out were you at all
worried when donald trump was running
for president and he may have said it
after he got elected i don't remember
but he definitely said it on the
campaign trail where he was like hey you
know what we're going to open up the
libel
uh cases because he wanted to go after
the press in a way that was
rare for you know all presidents and all
presidential candidates all politicians
[ __ ] and moan about the press but he
was saying i wanted to open up the libel
laws kind of pull back on the sullivan
case and other protections
that newspapers or media people have in
kind of talking about public figures do
you think he had a negative effect on
journalism in that way
you know i i wasn't really worried when
he said it because
he couldn't change new york times verse
sullivan what does worry me
is uh
the that two supreme court justices have
called for revisiting new york times
verse sullivan and one of them unlike
the president they actually could change
yeah is that uh was clarence thomas one
of them uh justice thomas has done it
twice uh but then justice gorsuch most
recently he didn't say we need to
overturn it he just said we need to
consider whether
it is still relevant in these times and
it's unclear whether
any other colleagues agree with them on
that
but we actually last year we had a judge
on the dc circuit judge silverman
write something that was
really
a stinging invective on the liberal
media yeah and
as part of it was a dissent where he
basically said we need i think the
supreme court needs to get rid of new
york times for sullivan
because the press
is so biased toward the democratic party
and they could be used for authoritarian
means and
that was pretty that was scary yeah
because i i mean i i don't think we're
quite there yet in the supreme court
overturning sullivan but i can say that
from practical experience both
representing media companies and being a
journalist
that there will be a substantial
chilling effect
uh on overturning sullivan if you
overturn sullivan you know i i think of
people like nadine strassen late of the
aclu and others who talk about how you
know the supreme court has been pretty
damn great on um on free speech issues
and first amendment issues generally for
the you know the past 30 or 40 years
much better than the population do you
think that's still true that uh you know
that the supreme court is pretty firmly
on the side of expanding speech and
expression and assembly rights or is
that starting to turn or is it and just
to make the question more convoluted and
longer it seems like the broader society
is kind of getting sick and tired or fed
up with the with free speech and is it
that you know does the supreme court
ultimately follow public opinion uh when
it when it starts kind of making
decisions about things like anonymity
but also just kind of more free willing
discussions of everything
i i worry that they might and i i think
there is a lack of appreciation i mean
i'll give one example that
i i've i started i only started using
twitter a few years ago actually to
promote my section 230 book and i kind
of got tracked
big mistake that has proven to be hasn't
it
and i somehow got dragged into a debate
where some someone asked me
um
what can the fcc do to stop tucker
carlson yeah and i said nothing because
the fcc doesn't regulate
cable news i even somehow i'm sure he
appreciates it i somehow dragged ajit
pai who was yeah the chairman of the fcc
to agree with me to say yes the fcc does
not have authority to regulate cable tv
channels
but that didn't there were people who
basically said he didn't know what he
was talking about
why would he know but even if the fcc
had statutory authority to regulate
cable tv channels what they're saying is
they want them they want fox news shut
down right because it spreads
misinformation
and what i've been trying to have a
dialogue i i shouldn't try to have a
dialogue but i've tried to
say you know can you possibly imagine
a president
who says that media outlets
that are not friendly are fake news and
that they're misinformation yeah just
imagine it oh no that wouldn't happen
because we wouldn't let them get into
power as the response right of course
and it's so short-sighted um
but it worries me because and this isn't
just coming
from
sort of fringe elements this is coming
from
i mean i've had in on the sullivan case
i've had some very
mainstream people from both parties
say to me you know why do we still have
sullivan yeah and so i think yeah
very clearly sullivan sullivan really
raises the bar uh to uh for a public
figure to be able to sue a media outlet
or somebody for defamation or liable
yeah exactly yeah and
it's uh and it's not the only protection
and i mean in practice there are other
there are other defenses that in many
cases are actually more useful than the
than the actual malice requirement but
it's definitely a key component right
and it's also something i mean i think
about this a lot because every every
survey every poll seems to show the
younger people are the less they
privilege or prioritize free speech
you know they think it needs to be
balanced or it's not all that and
we may have i think we're you know
within
you know spitting distance of each other
in age and
we may have grown up in this moment of
maximal free speech culturally where
people were really pushing the envelope
and i think i for a long time i mistook
that as universal i thought that's the
way it always was but obviously pre
sullivan it wasn't when you look back at
the
[ __ ] court cases of stuff that was
being banned as obscene
like into the early 60s it's just nuts
and then because of the lack of
alternative outlets the fcc can regulate
content on broadcast uh you know uh
radio and tv like stuff wasn't being
said in a way now we we have an infinite
number of places to curse and to shake
our fists at clouds but yeah this might
be this might just be this blip really
in a in a longer history of kind of
fairly uh fairly tight suppression of
speech
yeah absolutely i i do worry that we
that it isn't necessarily a linear
trajectory yeah and i i i think we might
we might be going in the other direction
do you worry about i mean your book on
section 230 uh is you know the
definitive account um it is widely cited
clearly not as widely read but i hope
that you you know i hope the check
clears on every purchase of the book for
you regardless
um but you know both uh republicans and
democrats in the senate in congress you
know well it's a you know it's a rare
day that somebody somewhere is in
bashing section 230 and saying it needs
to be gotten rid of
um is that do you think that's a live
threat and if so um would that be a
terrible thing
i think it is a threat i think maybe
perhaps a little less now than it was a
year ago because
i i think even the cr so
starting really in 2019 when
which coincided with my book coming out
section 230 has been a proxy for
people's anger at big tax so we're angry
at big tech either for taking too much
stuff down or keeping too much stuff up
so
that means we got a repeal section 230.
and
i think those arguments have been
tested quite a bit in public hearings in
the media and i think we're at least
moving away a little bit from that as
seeing section 230 is
the solution to everything right now the
problem is that people are still very
angry at big tech companies but they
might be realizing okay do we look at
other avenues and
a lot of those avenues are blocked not
because of section 230 but because of
the first amendment right and could you
explain that briefly because this i
think is very important but it it
doesn't seem to sink into a lot of
people
yeah so i mean i i'd say that so one
i'll give one example when my book came
out the
i was interviewed by the new york times
for my first time ever and i was so
excited i was like wow i'm gonna be in
the new york times um i spoke with the
reporter for an hour and there was like
a two word quote that was used but that
was still cool
but
i was
pretty shocked because it was basically
across the entire front of the business
section
the headline and i don't have it in
front of me so i can't recall exactly
what it said but it said something like
um hate speech is everywhere on the
internet and then it showed the 26 words
of section 230 and then underneath it it
said because this law protects it right
they had to run a correction
that said
it's actually not section 230 but the
first amendment that protects hate
speech yeah which is like kind of the
whole premise of the article
and
i i think that that's an illustration of
a lot of there's a lot of bad stuff
sort of lawful
awful but lawful type of
content that
you could get rid of section 230
protections for it
but
it's still gonna you you can't ban it
and i mean i'm currently writing a book
about misinformation and
while misinformation is depending on how
you categorize it if it's defamatory you
can go after it but i mean the supreme
court held in 2012 that there's not sort
of a categorical
uh exception to the first amendment for
false speech that there's a lot of
reasons why we protect false speech
and that so there's a lot of that stuff
that basically we don't like it so we
want to amend section 230 but you can't
because it's first amendment protected
and then on the other side you have
people who are angry the platforms are
taking down too much content and they
say well section 230 protects the the
platforms and it does
provide a defense
an early defense in these search of
claims but
unless you're going to adopt a theory
that i strongly disagree with that
social media companies are like the
phone company right um there's a first
amendment right of the platform to be
able to take down content yeah where
where did that noxious notion you know
and i i come across this on almost on a
daily basis where people say you know
you you're either a publisher or you're
a platform and that's in section 230 and
that's the law like you can't be both
that's why they pass section 230 which
of course
mentions none of that but
that argument that uh you either have to
be a platform kind of like the phone
company where your twitter i guess and
you just anybody can use you and you all
you do is make sure that the messages
get routed through
um but you don't get to have any
discretion over what is actually
published or passes through your content
where did that come from
i don't know the origin of it i can say
it really started in 2019 when there was
all this debate about big tech and
you had a lot of prominent politicians
saying it but i don't know who actually
developed
that theory but i mean i i spent a lot
of time
everywhere i could in the media with
in meetings with staffers just saying
you know this isn't
it's not the requirement actually the
the reason why congress passed section
230 was that they were concerned that
the existing first amendment protections
would actually discourage
platforms from moderation and they
actually wanted more moderation so
um i don't know where it came from and i
i think that people are moving away from
it a little bit and
now more of the argument is
you know the platforms are being unfair
so why do we give them this great
protection under section 230
um why do we treat them differently if
they're going to be biased and i mean
that
there's some
so some credibility to that argument i
mean i i could see why you would say
that and
to be fair there have been some
bad decisions from platforms and it's
hard because you're moderating a huge
amount of content at scale
but what i think is missing from that
argument is if you get rid of section
230
they're going to be blocking a whole lot
more content right because
suddenly they're going to face much more
liability potentially
and so if something's right on the edge
of being defamatory right now the
platforms can say well we're going to
determine
whether it's within our
user content guidelines but
without 230 if i'm any rational type of
platform i'm gonna say take it down or
just don't allow user comments at all
yeah
um one question i wanted to raise uh and
i think this cut you you mentioned in
the book it's partly because of your
experience as a journalist and obviously
you were doing some pretty hairy
investigative stuff there
you are in favor of journalism shield
laws and can you explain why because and
a shield law is something that would uh
and there are a lot of them at the state
level i there is not yet a federal uh
journal uh media shield law but this
would keep journalists from having to
divulge anonymous sources in legal
proceedings right
yeah and so
most states have some sort of shield law
protection at the federal level we don't
have a statute
we do have at least a fairly weak it
depends on the circuit constitutional
protection
that says in certain cases primarily
civil cases there's going to be a
balancing test
but it's pretty weak and the reason why
i'm
so passionate about this is exactly
right it was
the project that i told you about
where i was getting information and we
were facing various legal threats and
i had to get this information from
people
i had to say to them that they wouldn't
talk to me or give me documents
unless i said
you know i will not tell anyone who you
are and you can have varying agreements
you could say you know i won't tell
anyone who you are until i'm subpoenaed
right and you can try that but people
are going to reasonably say no that's
not good enough
and
um it's it's a horrible position to be
in sure to make that decision of saying
you know this is information we want to
get out
but we have to make the decision about
whether we would be willing
to go to jail to do our job did texas
have a shield law when you were working
um
so from what i i i don't remember
i i remember there at least being a risk
of
of possibly if there was a subpoena i
mean i
in that case
there were other cases where it was much
more likely now this wasn't the only
project that i worked on
because my my concern about a shield law
is that it creates it i always worry
about it as a backdoor
way of the government regulating the
press or licensing the press because
suddenly then you have journalists who
are real journalists because they
the state will say oh yeah well you work
for the oregonian you work for reason
you work for a legitimate outlet but you
you know mr pajama pants
you're not a real journalist so you're
not going to be covered and that i worry
about that yeah and i mean that's a
legitimate concern and i think that that
came up in
the last time that we had any real
substantive debate at the federal level
of the shield law it was right around
2013
and that came up um
in the hearings there were some members
who said you know
do we want to extend it at the time the
concern was
if anyone just starts a blog will they
suddenly be considered a journalist and
there was a reasonable definition i
think it was senator schumer who was
taking the lead interestingly uh
uh one of the people who wrote some one
of the most thoughtful bills
was uh then congressman mike pence
he was actually the one one of the
uh strongest supporters in congress of a
shield law but i i think that you could
look at you know what the primary
business model is um yeah and not
necessarily you know
not having a licensing regime or
anything right i mean i i guess i want
the first amendment you know the first
amendment i guess guarantees freedom of
the press but it doesn't define the
press and
we all have a printing press now so
we're all journalists
i like to think but yeah i mean i think
that you could define it functionally i
mean i i i agree with the concern but i
mean i think when the alternate
alternative is just don't have any
protection right and have a journal have
like another matthew cooper or judith
miller situation yeah
that's not i i mean i i i think that it
would be definitely an improvement do
you think and this might be beyond the
uh
uh your scope of interest or expertise
what about somebody like julian assange
and wikileaks and you know obviously
this is a you know unbelievably
complicated
uh case but
he is doing something that journalists
are known to do right where you you
receive documents that are gotten
you know illegally but as a journalist
you have a you have a right to publish
these things right
yeah i i have some pretty strong
feelings about that but i think i'll
pass on
elaborating
on that so uh just to uh as a as a wrap
up about the united states of anonymous
you you write at at one point that you
you have concluded in the book
that the benefits of america's strong
anonymity protections far outweigh the
harms from thomas paine to manuel talley
to the anonymous of anonymous employees
of the late 90s yahoo finance boards
anonymous speakers have often been those
who sought to challenge existing power
structures which is
wonderful i think and totally right
limiting either the laws or technology
that protect anonymity would too often
also restrict the ability to speak
freely about those in power that's
[ __ ] great um are you worried about
the future of online anonymity and where
are the biggest threats coming
yeah so i'm worried about it and
actually
the primary threat that i see is not
even the government but companies so
we've seen a number of high-profile
unmaskings of people in various contexts
where the unmasking is not because
someone's using a subpoena or the the
nsa is spying on someone
but it's that we have companies that
amass huge amounts of data about people
and it's not
everyone immediately thinks facebook and
google and i mean that's clearly google
with geolocation is
there's a lot of data
but what i'm even more concerned about
are data brokers that traffic in a lot
of identifying information the new york
times a few years ago did this great
story where
they purchased a file of geolocation
points and
i mean i
i have a long commute i live in
arlington virginia and i work at the
naval academy i'm probably one of the
only people
who does that so if you get a geo
location file
of someone's cell phone even my name's
not associated with it and you see
someone who every day is going from
arlington to annapolis
that's me and there's a i mean that
that's a so that's identifying but there
are no restrictions
on the on the sale the disclosure of
this data and so i i
think i know it's a lot to ask congress
to pass laws yeah no i mean yeah they're
very busy uh yeah yeah yeah they're very
busy talking about cuties or whatever
yeah or daylight savings time yeah yeah
no
yeah
but i think that
our failure to have
an effective national privacy law is
really shameful and
we have states doing these laws that are
well intentioned but
what they basically do is they just
create more bureaucracy
and they create longer privacy policies
and what they effectively say is
you know we're going to give user
individuals the choice and the ability
to request companies delete their data
and that's a good thing i mean that
that's a positive step but the problem
is for data brokers i mean i work in the
field and i don't know all the data
brokers that have my data so i don't
know who to go to
and i think that a better way in
addition to giving people choice is
to say
there are certain types of data use that
we and
collection that we just will not
tolerate
and
we're going to say companies can't do
certain things so
you can't sell facial recognition
databases to local police and i mean
some local governments have prohibited
the use of by their police of that data
and i think that's the sort of model
that we need to have so that's really
the biggest threat that i see to
anonymity ultimately ultimately is it um
you know
are we foolish to rely on laws as
opposed to you know kind of a public
consensus and that's very soft and vague
but also
technology because you know it's partly
technology is what drives the collect
you know the ability to speak
anonymously but also the ability to be
caught speaking anonymously and is it
ultimately you know maybe
you you will be driving and you will
have something on your phone you know
which is obviously i mean our phones are
like
you know they're they're bugs you know
in like old movies when you know a spy
would put a bug on the back of a car
like we're carrying the bugs with us
maybe we come up with a way of
anonymizing you know our location and
all of that kind of stuff i mean it
seems
i want to believe in laws that are
effective and that work as intended and
then don't create the next monstrosity
you know that we need to deal with but
um do you think it might be more of a
technological
fix or a cultural fix where we say you
know what we're just we're not going to
be doing this sort of thing anymore
i think it's a combination of both
technology culture and law i i don't
think it's one or the other so and i
mean tor for example which i profile how
it was created and
it's been tremendously useful especially
in
the arab spring i mean that it was
crucial in that
but there are some downsides including
that it's very slow um so
that but it but it's partially useful
useful i think law can help i also think
i i spend a chapter talking about people
who think that they're anonymous when
they're posting online but they give
enough clues
that they're unmasked and so i think
part of it is just self
responsibility that you know you you're
going to
recognize that if you give enough pieces
of the puzzle
people are going to be able to put it
together so individuals ultimately
have to say do i need to put everything
on instagram or well i think the answer
is clearly yes but that might be a
different conversation do you think that
we're also you know speaking of people
like assange and wikileaks edward
snowden comes to mind chelsea manning i
mean those those are kind of the high
profile people who reveal
things particularly about governments
but then there's also the panama papers
and there's all other sorts of things
we're living in an era of kind of force
transparency where whether you like it
or not you're going to be you know your
nudes are going to show up somewhere and
that the
you know that we need to learn
new ways of dealing with that and living
with that and i think we have in many
ways when you look at something like
uh you know a celebrity a celebrity sex
table leak six the sex tape in the 80s
destroyed the career of a female
sportscaster named jane kennedy it made
the career of kim kardashian and paris
hilton and that i don't you know i don't
want to put too much weight on this but
it's almost like our social evolution to
be like when we're in a world where
people can take
a lot of compromising photos we're going
to become more chill about that um you
know and in terms of forced transparency
are we gonna you know do we really first
what we have to do is kind of upgrade to
the next you know iteration of our
social program system to just be like
we're gonna learn a lot more about each
other and we're gonna have to just learn
not to freak out or become really
tendentious about how we use this data
yeah i mean i think that might be part
of it i mean i i think asking americans
not to freak out is
a pretty tall task yeah when you put it
that way i withdraw the entire point but
yeah but but yeah i mean i i think that
the problem is that and i hear the
argument a lot uh about just anonymity
in general there are a lot of proposals
now to require real names on social
media yeah and
i worry that
i think for a large segment of the
population
they probably would not be terribly
burdened by a real-time requirement but
i think that
is perhaps the segment of the population
that has the luxury of being able to
post under their real names right
i i think that particularly marginalized
groups groups that have various very
good reasons
for being anonymous don't have that
ability and aren't going to
in the near future jillian york at the
electronic frontier foundation
she calls uh proposals for real names
she calls them the white man's gambit
because she says you know
white guys who are able to post with
their real names yeah and i i think
there's
there's a lot of truth to that yeah for
sure okay we're going to leave it there
the book is the united states of
anonymous the author is just jeff kossif
thanks so much for talking to reason
thanks for having me
[Music]